stand by Gino a former Secret Service
agent he joins us tonight so there's a
huge controversy online that I'm
hesitant even to weighed in on but I
think it needs to be addressed and it's
over the protests led by the students
for whom all of us feel terrible because
we can't imagine anything worse than
your kid school getting shot up but all
of a sudden you're seeing these kids
involved in calls for very specific
pieces of legislation and the allegation
has been that they are in some way in
contact with organized anti-gun groups
and people who have suggested that have
been denounced as immoral and heartless
and how dare you question these kids are
attacked them which for the record I am
certainly not doing right but I think it
raises interesting questions about how
we make our law right you know what's
interesting about this is I'm with you
100% if you are involved in a horrific I
mean unimaginable tragedy like this you
absolutely your voice should be heard
they are obviously important voices in
what happened but what I find ironic
about it is a couple things number one
where I think their voices are most
valuable Tucker are not on the
components the media is paying attention
to in other words supply Sinemet supply
side measures to get rid of god yes
where their voices would be valuable is
where were the signs missed these
students were there they dealt with this
kid every day but the media's focused
more on a teenager's expertise in supply
side control measures for guns which
Tucker let's be candid they probably
have not studied a very complicated
layered issue they absolutely
unequivocally have the right and and
after what they've been through we want
to hear their voices but the media is
focusing on an agenda and not ironically
where these kids well they're using
these kids in a kind of moral blackmail
where you're not allowed to disagree or
you're attacking the child which is of
course I can speak for myself the last
thing I would ever do is a father of
four yeah I would never attack the kid
you can disagree with other people's
opinions without attacking them but the
press's is conflating that and making it
like you're not allowed to disagree
you're a bad word well did you notice
the doublespeak here as well when it
comes to things like immigration rights
they don't seek subject-matter expertise
for parents have been killed by illegal
immigrants when it comes to things like
the victims of terrorist attacks their
voice is now
candid here I get it there they can say
someone may come back and say well
Republicans come out and I said what
about Kate's law fine but we gave them a
voice and we followed it up with a
substantive law and we understand and
I'm saying you these kids should be
heard but the left-leaning media will
not do the same they will give the these
kids a platform to talk about these
legislative issues but they won't give
anyone else on an issue that doesn't fit
their agenda the exact same right
creepy propaganda let's like CNN I guess
what I just disagree with is the idea
that anybody was an alternate view is
removed from the conversation on moral
grounds immediately that is there that
is their place well always I mean Tucker
no it's it's all critical theory stuff
is it's meant to minimize and put you it
wins the argument before the arguments
start by making sure Tucker Carlson's a
bad guy there for whatever Tucker
Carlson says is therefore unworthy of
the conversation that's such a spark I
wish I did expressed it as crispy as you
just did thank you I hope that was good
she's impressed